we had a big problem with airbnb and
i've been a big proponent of airbnb and
airbnb is a billion dollar business
and it's valued at how much do you mean
they just had a ipo right
airbnb is uh this massive
uh i mean it is just
it's 68 dollars a share i mean
it's it's 33 billion valuation as of
november 30th for airbnb
okay now it's targeting december 7th 42
billion
variation for airbnb and we had a
problem with airbnb
we had a real issue with airbnb i have
done
nothing but be respectful to the people
to the homes that i rent i've done
nothing you understand
i do not get bad reviews on airbnb
because i treat people with respect
now let's describe let's describe some
of the issues
number one i went i was told i was going
to a luxury compound in joshua tree
luxury means something very specific to
me
okay it doesn't mean necessarily
stylized high concept and artistic it
means luxury it means
fluffy couches and nice carpets luxury i
feel luxurious
you understand um we went to
a nice thing in joshua tree
which is the place where all people in
the tech industry go to take mushrooms
and
people that work for ice go and have you
know to take dmt and
figure out how to build stronger cages
to put kids in you know it's great it's
for people having revelations
so we go to joshua tree which is really
just it's a litter box for drug addicts
let's be honest yeah it's a litter box
for drug addicts and i know that a lot
of people like it but that's what it is
and that's who you
are so we go to this litter box for drug
addicts and they you know they've stuck
a little house on the edge of the
cliff and we can all go see the desert
and you know take a bunch of drugs and
see satan or whatever
and um we get into the house the house
the furniture in the house is like it's
all it's all
of course these are two white women i
believe they're lesbians i don't want to
i say that they're lesbians i don't know
but their names are stupid like one of
them's name is mila
it's like it's a stupid name you're a
ridiculous person okay
you accuse me of breaking a cactus how
do you even do that you goofy [ __ ] shut
the [ __ ] up
okay you slob so i walk into your
[ __ ] house which you can't even sit
on the [ __ ] front i got
fat people here they're 400 pounds how
are they gonna sit on your cowhide chair
that's a little thin thing of [ __ ]
leather what are we supposed to do
this guy's 900 pounds what are we gonna
do here
okay every piece of furniture
can't sodomize the guest you have to
have some [ __ ] chair that works
like an actual [ __ ] chair throw a
beanbag in there
okay not everybody's a 90-foot 90-pound
lesbian on ayahuasca
that can perch on a [ __ ] bird cage
for the whole night okay you freaks
listen the [ __ ] up talking to you
people are going to rent your house that
are actual people that need actual
furniture to actually sit
not everything's a [ __ ] trip to
hyperspace
there's actual 3d reality that some of
us have to [ __ ] live
so we went there
and i was not thrilled with the decor
and i
i told you that it was very uh white and
you know these white [ __ ] they just
steal native american culture and i'm
not even a culturally appropriation guy
but
they just steal this [ __ ] culture
they put these weird little uh buffalo
heads skulls everywhere
and you know lavender oil and what am i
gonna do lube my ass with it what are
you
what is this so we go in
and it's all white the fireplace doesn't
work of course because the insurance
company won't insure them
everything's freezing the hot tub is
freezing
unhappy right the [ __ ] lock box we
gotta [ __ ] attack it to get the key
out
um so we're there in the house and
we do nothing to the furniture we
literally don't damage any of the
furniture they have these kitchen stools
that are concrete slabs
mila mila we work so hard for the shut
up
get a job there are concrete slab
kitchen chairs high top kitchen chairs
okay
that are like art pieces these are not
chairs and they have little stools that
are made out of what was that like
hollowed out so like marble or the the
marble
petrified wood petrified wood or i don't
know what it was
it's a little stool that you're supposed
to sit it's a tiny little table
where your ass can't even fit on this
small little thing of wood that you have
to sit on
and eat i don't even know what right so
they just want you doing drugs do you
walk in there's a big mortar and a
pestle there
i don't know like just crush it up just
crush it up and do it
get it into the butcher and that's fine
listen i got it i got janja
i tagged the shrimps but some people
want to have a nice
meal there we treated that house that
could have never been treated
it with wholesome american food
we went to vons in the desert and we got
burgers and bushes baked beans and we
cooked
baked beans and yes beans explode when
they're hot yeah
whose fault is that i didn't come up
with the idea for the bean
they explode without and then we wanted
uh gordon's fish we got the gorton's
fish which is very nice
the breaded pre-breaded gordon's fish
and some tartar sauce
so we so baked beans gorton's fish with
tartar sauce cheeseburgers and then
seven pints of ice cream so we could try
yeah
just have a little ice cream testing and
we left a few dishes
in the sink in the sink a pot of
exploded beans
an extra tartar sauce i didn't even use
that i said you can use
um some ice cream i mean the smell of
the house was fish
and bean yeah but that's not my fault
you couldn't have a cleaning because
she's like the cleaning crew complained
what what is it my fat maid over there
probably complaining
but it's like well why are they
complaining they're supposed to be
cleaning their job is to clean
okay so this [ __ ] then texts me she
goes our cleaning crew had a heart
attack lol so i'm like okay
and then she goes but please give us a
good review should we stay on airbnb so
here's the deal with airbnb we review
each other we don't know what we've said
if you're going to come reach out to me
and ask me for a good review and
acknowledged that the cleaning crew was
like oh we got to wash some dishes
i'm like okay they're not mad we didn't
do anything there's some dishes in the
sink but it is what it is i paid a 400
cleaning fee you stupid [ __ ] jonah and
mila
you [ __ ] pigs i'll burn your [ __ ]
house down
by the way anyway i texted them that i
texted them i was gonna burn their house
down
and i sent them a gif of the simpsons
house burning i'm like i know where your
house is they're like are you
threatening me i'm like let's just see
what happens
i'm like stay safe out there you stupid
desert dykes
i will have god hates [ __ ] church
outside of your [ __ ] house every
[ __ ] day
i will call uh who is the people in
there who are the
westboro baptist yeah westborough and
who are the names uh fred phelps the
phelps family
i'll get the whole fouls family not the
[ __ ] that went on rogue and the rest of
them that stayed true
i will get them out there every [ __ ]
night to [ __ ] yell at the people
renting your stupid drug den
anyway so i responded to her by saying
no one broke anything your house sucks
because she said i was a bad guest and
then and then people are like did this
really happen so it can't really happen
i said the few the furniture is unusable
you're not artist your home is wildly
overpriced true
you begged me for a good rating and then
trashed me the cleaning crew complained
about cleaning who's your cleaning crew
there were some dishes that is all i
don't really care about your reviews i
don't rent up my home to strangers like
an animal good luck with everything in
the future
the place is a dump and it looks like it
was furnished by drug addicts
which i imagine you are please get the
help you need if you want me to take you
to an aaa meeting or an n a meeting i
will go to ikea
get some actual furniture which
hopefully you can afford not everything
has to be an art piece
and feel free to use the tartar sauce i
left behind later
pig and that's what i wrote to them on
airbnb and no response
and then i and then i sent a few that
could have been considered
quasi-threatening messages but they were
not threats they were an art piece
like your furniture they're not meant to
be sat on or taken literally i was doing
an
art piece you see it was all a metaphor
and an anger it angered me because she
[ __ ] on me publicly on airbnb which
anyone can see
truly and now i look like the bad guy
i look like the bad guy
jonah and mila [ __ ] you
we didn't do anything dishes were in the
sink
the hot tub wasn't hot you already paid
400 for a clean if we're not supposed to
eat the gorton's fish why would they
sell it
at the supermarket
i'm not getting fresh fish i trust the
gorton's fisherman yeah
and it's a lovely if you've ever had a
gorton's they're
lovely very good and then the mccormick
tartar sauce goes very well with it it
pairs very well
i'm sorry i wasn't doing speed balls in
your bathroom
like the rest of your guests
you [ __ ] pigs you've done nothing
but create a [ __ ] satanic vortex for
people to sin
and i didn't take part in it i made
bowls of baked beans
i'll i will not toler i will not
tolerate
being disparaged publicly like that
and this good man does he he did nothing
wrong
he slept in a room where the sun
hit him directly in the face as soon as
it came up cause there were no [ __ ]
curtains
yeah because curtains are too basic for
these [ __ ]
hoes and i hope they hear this by the
way i hope someone in your garbage life
shows you this podcast you are nothing
do you understand me
you clowns look at your airbnb picture
you're
you pose with your [ __ ] dogs you're
clowns
you're not interesting and you were not
an artist you are failures and you were
drug addicts
and i'm telling you right now if you had
any clue the holy hell that was about to
rain down
on you you would [ __ ] run you would
have you would run out into the desert
and sacrifice yourself
cause every day i swear to christ every
[ __ ] day i wake up and i think about
how to destroy you and that [ __ ]
and i'll figure it out and see this is
what i mean about the cops can't call me
out on this because it's my right
to kind of vent these frustrations and i
can't because they can't knock on my
door and say hey did you say you're
going to kill these
two dykes and joshua tree i can't this
is what i mean do you see in real time
i'm proving my point from the beginning
of the show that's why the show is
entertaining
and it's informative because the reality
is we're all having these thoughts all
the time
because what i really want to do is gas
these two in their house and watched
them just
i want to watch them [ __ ] climb over
their shitty art house furniture and get
to the [ __ ] door and just
just they can't get any breath and then
fall and then just walk in and i want to
piss on their corpses but i'm not going
to do that
i'm not going to do that
i'm just going to talk about it do you
understand the difference
and if putting on a hispanic accent made
me feel a little better
if being a little exotic made me feel
better if pretending to be an eastern
european
or pretending to be a russian or
pretending to be asian if that made me
feel a little better if it got me
through my day
if it decreased the chances and i was
going to go back and burn this [ __ ]
[ __ ] all down in the middle of joshua
tree
because they've wronged me if that made
me feel a little better than what the
[ __ ] wrong with that what is the
problem
with that i'm not putting pig heads on
pelosi's door i just want to go hey come
and see this
cucumber i don't know how to talk in the
english i don't know how to do it
so what's the [ __ ] problem out there
pick and choose your battles do you
understand
and i hope and this show's a big show i
hope to god
someone shows it to these people and i
will get in a high-profile war with both
of you ladies
okay cause i'm a [ __ ] too okay
you can't do that straight white man
[ __ ] on me okay
i will suck a [ __ ] in your house and
then burn it down
i don't know what that'll prove it
sounded more progressive as i was saying
it
it actually sounded quite hateful as i
was saying it as well
my point is this stop there's nothing
worse than lesbians who think they're
artists
you're not just build a [ __ ] shed you
apes